Hola bienvenidos una nueva emisión de la
entrevista de Francis 4 en español en
esta oportunidad nos acompaña Lucía
lubarsky ella es directora productora
audiovisual y también poeta entre muchos
otros trabajos realizados es directora y
guionista de la película documental el
silencio de los hombres en esta a través
de múltiples testimonios indaga los
mandatos de la masculinidad de
hegemónica el peso con el que recaen
sobre las identidades masculinas y como
las marcas dejándolas atravesadas por el
silencio por lo no dicho y por todo un
Universo de temores Lucía luarsky
Muchísimas gracias por tu presencia en
Franz 24
qué tal un gusto Santiago Gracias por el
espacio y por el interés por supuesto
una vez más bueno contanos Cómo nace el
silencio de los hombres de hecho Este es
un cuestionamiento que te hace no tu
padre Al final el del documental y que
precisamente Bueno a mí me vino al
comienzo de verlo
creo que inicialmente la película
nace más de una inquietud que que
venimos como haciéndonos las personas
que venimos transitando las luchas
feministas de distintos desde distintos
lugares y que muchas veces la inquietud
es que pasa con los varones y las
masculinidades que se están preguntando
Cómo se están organizando Cómo se están
encontrando Y qué tipo de inquietudes
tienen Qué tipo de inquietudes pueden
compartir
y en última instancia después Cómo
pueden socializar No esas esas preguntas
esos deseos esos temores porque de
alguna manera los feminismos nos
encontraron a las mujeres y a las
disidencias generando distintos tipos
nuevos tipos de discursos de
posicionamiento de lecturas y todo el
tiempo la pregunta que de alguna manera
nos volvían rebotaba era y los varones
que pasan no dónde están que se están
preguntando cuál y inicialmente la
película iba a tener como una mirada un
poco más observacional donde yo y mi
historia personal no iba a ser parte
pero luego pandemia mediante y un montón
de preguntas que me fui haciendo en
distintos laboratorios
empezó a salir la pregunta de cuál era
mi anclaje y cuál era mi punto de vista
respecto de esto y bueno y encontré todo
una cadena ahí de de mandatos de
preguntas en el linaje masculino de mi
familia que me pareció un punto muy
interesante de partida para pensar en
estas problemáticas en estos Silencio en
estas cosas no dichas que se van negando
de generación en generación Y de alguna
manera van generando una especie de de
herencia no de de mandato y Qué pasa
cuando esas cosas empiezan a
resquebrajar en la generaciones nuevas
indagaré luego un poco más adelante
Lucía sobre Bueno este universo Familiar
no que es tan importante en la película
documental pero Bueno antes preguntarte
por esto que ya comenzabas a deslizar no
con qué te encontraste en Qué temas En
qué momentos cuando sentías que surgía o
que aparecía no lo no dicho ese silencio
Mirá
Había algo muy muy interesante que me
pareció que se repetían en muchas porque
bueno quizás en algún momento lo
mencionamos pero El Punto de partida de
alguna manera es mi familia pero luego
entrevistamos a otros varones y además
continuamos como compartiendo y
observando la vida de tres varones en
particular no sin embargo hay
entrevistas de de muchos varones de
distintas procedencias orígenes franjas
etarias y había algo que se repetía en
muchos de ellos que tenía que ver con
con una dificultad muy grande de
compartir todo lo que tiene que ver con
las prácticas por ejemplo vinculadas con
lo sexual con los miedos con lo que no
saben hacer con lo que no le salió como
pensaban esta cuestión de la dificultad
de poder compartir con otro no esa
frustraciones estos lugares donde
supuestamente deberían tener una cierta
performance donde
ahí se juega y se pone en escena está
masculinidad que se espera no esta
cuestión de saber de ir hacia adelante
de proponer de tener siempre de alguna
manera una respuesta y de medirse hay
algo que vi en muchos de ellos que tiene
que ver con que hay algo que se instala
como como marca y como como signo casi
diría como estigma de la masculinidad
que es como la competencia No desde
pequeños está en el juego está en el
deporte luego está en la performance
sexual luego está en en lo económico en
lo profesional entonces me parece que
hay algo que se genera ahí un nudo muy
grande en la identidad que que muchas
veces lo vi como algo enclaustrante
donde no poder relajar esa especie de
carrera sin fin que hay que demostrar un
montón de de de de de de pasos no y y de
de capacidades
creo que hace que en algún punto también
veía muchos varones sumidos mucha
soledad no poder Mostrar todo aquello
que es lo que supuestamente queda fuera
de eso que es lo que se espera de lo
masculino no esa también esa cuestión
muy hacia afuera de de lo que es lo
laboral lo lo lo profesional todo lo que
tiene que ver con lo que está por fuera
del mundo del mundo doméstico y
posiblemente hay otros varones que
tienen otros deseos otras necesidades y
que se caen de lo que es como las
frontera de la masculinidad Y qué pasa
con esos deseos que se corren de ese
Canon no yo creo que ahí hay un
enquistamiento muy grande me refiero a
varones que quizás son
heterosexuales
que más entre comillas varones más
tradicionales y sin embargo tienen un
montón de otras inquietudes deseos o
recorridos en potencia que no han podido
desarrollar porque Quizás por miedo por
vergüenza por no poder compartirlos con
otros y que hay muchos otros a los que
también les pasa algo similar eso me
resulta muy interesante porque creo que
hay mucho camino por recorrer ahí y
mucho para abrir No mucho para dejar de
claro esto que planteas no del vínculo
con el otro además como decíamos en la
película documental hay muchísimos
testimonios varones heterosis varones
trans varones homosexuales pero parte de
tu familia tiene un rol muy fuerte en el
documental Lucía en este podemos ver
videos de tu infancia Incluso en el
campo testimonios de tu padre de tu
hermano diálogos entre ellos porque
elegiste ir a tu núcleo familiar a ese
epicentro más primario verdad de
nuestros vínculos
Mira una de las preguntas que está igual
en el trailer y digo está dando vueltas
por ahí tiene que ver un poco con mi
hermano cuando yo le propongo ser parte
del documental y él me dice para qué me
querés entrevistar a mí si yo soy un
tipo normal No soy un tipo común no
tengo nada distinto para y justamente
algo que me pareció interesante era que
estos dos varones que son mi padre y mi
hermano que son dos tipos comunes entre
las mil comillas de lo que se puede
pensar como como lo normal la normalidad
son dos varones regulares son dos
varones que que de hecho digo tienen una
relación afectuosa pero aún así dentro
de una relación afectuosa tienen un
montón de mandatos y de cadenas de
legados que caen como pesos sobre lo que
luego va a ser el desarrollo de su
propia vida de su identidad y de lo que
ellos pueden hacer con sus deseos
entonces me pareció que era un Punto de
partida bastante entre bastante
universal porque es verdad digo hay
otros varones que son más disidentes en
la película pero no son mi padre y mi
hermano y me pareció que esa historia
entre ese padre y ese hijo y eso Esas
expectativas que que de alguna manera
van cayendo en degeneración en
generación en generación Más allá de la
extracción social de la que vengan en
este caso Ellos hablan de un mundo de
campo y una extracción de clase media
acomodada yo soy muy consciente eso pero
ese tipo de legados y de mandatos en la
línea masculina Me parece que que es
transversal a un montón de extracciones
sociales y un montón de orígenes y puede
ser
el legado de por ejemplo de la profesión
de un carpintero de un maestro de un
veterinario de un obrero y la
expectativa de que esa línea continúe no
que haya que continúe en esa en esa
línea en esa genética en esa familia y
Qué pasa cuando hay en que decide seguir
un poco más su deseo que se corre del
mandato y todo lo que se resquebrajan y
no hay algo y eso me parece interesante
porque creo que es extrapolable a casi
todas las historias de padres e hijos
entonces me parece que que eso puede
generar una puerta de entrada
interesante en términos también de
empatía y que los espectadores y
picadoras pueden verse ahí posiblemente
reflejados o conocen historias muy
similares absolutamente y te digo que
está muy logrado eso Lucía De hecho tu
propio trabajo logró generar más
diálogos y algunos ciertos
cuestionamientos incluso no entre tu
papá y tu hermano abriste conversaciones
barriste quizás con cierto silencios que
había y cosas no dichas que había entre
ellos en este sentido quisiera
preguntarte qué crees que hace falta
para comenzar a destrabar todas esas
cosas guardadas no y no dichas
Mira yo no tengo ninguna claramente digo
no quiero me me me me me me
ve a pudor Yo soy una realizadora y una
documentalista y entro También en estos
territorios con muchísima inquietud con
respeto y con mucha más preguntas que
respuestas qué es lo que de alguna
manera siempre
insisto en que la película propone
cuando de repente quieren quieren decir
que en la película
diezmamos los derechos del hogar todo lo
contrario yo lo que quise hacer es abrir
un diálogo Para proponer una escucha Y
creo que justamente los testimonios que
están ahí es porque la escuchas Tú
porque se sintieron los hombres lo
suficientemente
respetados y cómodos para que eso suceda
creo que algo que yo veo crucial es que
los varones puedan empezar a comunicarse
más entre ellos yo lo que vi que sucedió
entre mi entre sobre mi padre lo que
veía que sucedía una vez que apagamos la
cámara entre el equipo y entre las
personas entrevistadas las personas del
equipo que yo inicialmente quería que
sean todas mujeres y luego estuvo
bárbaro que no sean solamente mujeres
sino que haya varones se generaba todo
un diálogo donde los mismos varones del
equipo se sentían interpelados por lo
que decían las personas frente a cámara
y había mucha identificación y había
algo que que yo vi que lo vi reiterada
situaciones que tenía que ver con que
esa identificación hacía que la persona
que estaba hablando y abriéndose se
sintiera menos sola Y aquel que se
sintió identificado con ese testimonio
también entonces hay un efecto de
réplica y de amplificación en eso en la
que me parece que hay que de alguna
manera agrietar todo lo que tenga que
ver con ese sistema que genera una
soledad absoluta donde los varones lo
que veo es que muchas veces les cuesta
abrir y destrabar ese silencio que de
alguna manera los los constriñe por
completo Entonces yo creo que hay que
animarse para ser un poco el pudor
porque me parece que hay mucho más
varones que están sintiendo cosas
similares a otros Solo que no están
pudiendo ponerlos en relación y
compartirlo
Lucía Se nos acabó el tiempo se ha
pasado rapidísimo seguiría hablando
contigo muchísimo más espero de hecho
volver a tener la oportunidad para que
lo hagamos Muchísimas gracias En serio
ha sido muy interesante esta entrevista
Muchísimas gracias a vos Santiago y al
Canal
una vez más a nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a que sigan
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y también por supuesto en
Franz 24.com y en todas nuestras redes
sociales sigan junto a nosotros